why you should eat overripe bananas a
yellow skin banana with dark spots on it
it is eight times more effective and
enhancing the properties of white blood
cells then green skin then then raw what
am I reading something wrong what is
happening here hey guys we've covered
Medical memes before we've reacted to
medical dramas but it never hit me to
talk about some of the crazy Instagram
posts that have to do with health I've
seen a lot of those you sent me them so
I thought I'd react to some of them I
feel like we're gonna be in for a
stressful video maybe a fun video a fun
stressful video I don't know let's find
out oh my god I'm just gonna read this
as is because I feel like I'm in the
twilight zone a yellow skin banana with
dark spots on it is eight times more
effective in enhancing the properties of
white blood cells then then green skin
version eating one two bananas a day
increases immunity that was just so
stressful to read I feel like whatever
health benefit you get by eating a
banana it was fully negated by reading
this meme slash Instagram post can
people eat bananas and help their immune
system help support their immune system
boosting and over boosting your immune
system is actually a really bad thing
autoimmune conditions like psoriasis
Crohn's disease of the intestines that
cause really bad problems for people is
an over boosted immune systems that
starts attacking things that are not
actually a threat to you did you know
once a week for 20 minutes first of all
this is a very lavish bathtub because
there's clouds or marshmallows plus
sticks and she doesn't quite fit in it
once a week for 20 minutes sit in a hot
tub that contains a handful of epsom
salts 10 drops of lavender essential oil
and a half cup of baking soda this combo
draws out toxins lower stress and
balances your ph levels
serenity now the essential oil community
is trying to get me frustrated it does
not balance your pH levels can you
imagine if enough
your ph level is so tightly controlled
like between seven point three five and
seven point four five is it's like
little range that it lives in and if it
comes out of that even slightly like if
it goes to six point nine you die can
you imagine in order to live you need it
to take a bath that looks like this
that's a problem folks you are not a
dish like if i was trying to balance the
ph levels of my chicken in a pot maybe
i'd want to throw some lemon followed by
baking soda on it but you my friend are
not a piece of chicken in a pot good
source or protein is that a good source
or is it a protein we'll never know
improve vitality a sit metabolism
function because you know some our
metabolism function likes to stand and
we like for it to sit Privett migraine
headache lower risk of diabetes prevent
gall stones fight heart disease next
time my patient has a migraine headache
or is about to get one let's say hey why
don't you chill out and get a cashew can
you say it's a good source I don't know
like what is considered a good source of
protein it is a source of protein does
it improve vitality well like livelihood
like how happy you are does it sit does
it assist your metabolic function I mean
anything that you eat assists metabolic
function because your metabolisms gonna
start working does it prevent a migraine
headache that's ridiculous throw it out
there you know though I will say
something about cherries cherries have
natural aspirin in them very small
amounts some coconut regulates thyroid
function improves brain function
maintain body mass stimulate immunity
keeps heart healthy improves digestion
full of energy glowing skin I don't know
if they're saying positive things about
coconuts or this is what's gonna happen
to you if you eat a coconut like is the
coconut full of energy does the coconut
have glowing skin is to coconut rich in
fiber kind of getting mad here maintain
body mess that's what food does folks
have you ever eaten anything before I
can put that on every label I'm pretty
sure you can put that on a pillow like
I'm pretty sure if I put this on this
bear
pillow it will maintain body mess
probably walls but anything that's
edible anything that has a calorie helps
maintain body mass that one is
ridiculous regulates thyroid function no
you know what regulates thyroid function
thyroid stimulating hormone it
stimulates the thyroid to make hormone
you know what stimulates thyroid
stimulating hormone thyroid releasing
hormone glands baby not coconuts for
smelly underarms god I don't even know
where this is going just take a shower
that's what I'm thinking
take a shower bathe mix what freakin
science experiment my god just wash
yourself and you won't have smelly
underarms can you imagine if you walk
into my home and you see I'm like
getting ready for a hospital day and you
see me measuring out coconut oil and
lemon juice and a teaspoon you asked me
what I'm doing and then without any
hesitation I just start throwing it on
my arm it's like would you judge me I
don't know if this works
maybe I should experiment with it I
don't think I have coconut oil here or
lemon juice and their representation of
smelly underarms is like there's ribbons
coming out of her armpits and she has
red cheeks maybe she has an infection
let's select size for a second and leave
this for a moment the reason why our
underarms actually smell bacteria farts
there's bacteria that generally live in
your armpit area and we can fight that
bacteria because when that bacteria
starts consuming little things that are
on your skin surface
it sucks farting and smelling real bad
but apparently I learned something new
today lemon juice and coconut oil might
try it probably not did you know that
what it snows your eyes just by eating
five dates in a day helps you reduce the
chances of night blindness reduce hair
loss and risk of cancer it also helps to
improve your brainpower and eyesight
because it is high in fiber and
potassium take this meme is screaming at
me for some reason and this person's eye
looks like it has a cataract in it goo
goo cataract that looks like a cataract
are people suffering like people who
haven't had a date
I haven't eaten it I haven't consumed
the food known as a date in probably
five years does that mean I'm at higher
risk of night blindness I think not I
think that's not how life works
did you know eating one to two figs
soaked and water overnight helps in
faster weight loss as figs has high
fiber content prevent wrinkles makes
your skin soft and supple boost immune
system and promote hair growth two figs
are healthy food do they prevent
wrinkles no do they make your skin soft
and supple if your skin is not soft and
supple right now eating figs randomly
introducing it to your diet probably
won't change much man imagine life was
that simple like my skin is rough I have
two figs now I'm supple no more unwanted
facial hair DIY papaya before aloe vera
gel after
[Music]
are they saying papaya makes you have
hair and then aloe vera gel does not
like if you're gonna make a DIY you
can't just put the ingredients and go
DIY what do I do it do you slap the
papaya on your forehead and eat the aloe
vera gel all seriousness this looks like
it would be something targeted at
females if you are a female and you're
growing facial hair or hair in areas
that you haven't grown before and it's
troubling to you you should go speak
with your family medicine doctor if it's
happening in combination with other
symptoms that can be a sign of a problem
known as PCOS there's actually a medical
term for this unwanted type of hair in a
male pattern it's called her shoot ISM
don't be afraid to bring that up in one
of your visits I know some patients of
mine in the past have been hesitant to
bring it up but please don't be it's
something that happens it's treatable
it depends obviously what's causing it
but the answer is not a papaya and aloe
vera gel as much as that sounds
delicious it's not the treatment doing
this pose helps to DoubleTap oh it helps
to get rid of double chin it increases
the flexibility of the neck provide a
gentle massage to belly organs this
looks like just basic yoga cat-cow
that's fine
I love cat-cow I recommend it to my
patients I do it myself I do it in bed
in the morning when I wake up but why is
there a giant virus looking bubble
that's ladies back when she's doing cow
or cat not a cow no cats do this thing
or cats nope the cows around their back
does it help to get rid of double chin I
would say no double chin can come from I
guess a few factors one is being obese
you're gonna have more fat here you're
gonna create the appearance of a double
chin if you have bad posture I guess you
could have a two but doing this alone
won't solve that issue so I'm not a fan
to increases flexibility of the neck I
think it increases flexibility of the
spine and increases range of motion so
I'm with that one they went neck I'll
say spine same thing provide a gentle
massage to belly organs do you want to
massage your belly organs you know the
only organs you might want a massage
would be your intestines there's
actually certain ways that we can
activate your intestines if you're like
act up there are certain massages that
can help also prenatal massages but
massaging like your liver I've never
heard for that to be effective in any
sort of way oh it's not your liver your
stomach your gallbladder massage not
platters nice click here for my most
recent video on memes it's absolutely
hilarious or check out an older video on
how to not get sick I think it's more
applicable now than ever which one
you're clicking stay happy and healthy
[Music]